It is better to be feared than loved if you cannot be both.
So you might agree with this statement.
If you fancy yourself.
A Macchia,
Vallian Italian diplomat and Niccolo Machiavelli lived over funny of centuries
ago,
but its influence among unscrupulous politicians reaches into the modern age.
He is mostly known for writing a book called the Prince.
The handbook established him as the father of modern political theory through
its teachings.
Power is the ultimate goal through any means necessary.
Back who was born in Florence on May the third 1469 to Bernardo did Niccolo
Machiavelli a lawyer and his wife bought all the mayor to Stefan and Nelly.
He was the oldest son of his parents with two elder sisters and a younger
brother.
The backing of Elliot family,
it was an established middle class family,
not particularly affluent,
but they have means Machiavelli was born during a tumultuous time in history in
which the pope's waged war against the Italian city.
States and political alliances frequently changed eating to the swift rise and
fall of many short lived governments,
France,
Spain,
and the holy Roman Empire.
All battled for regional control and influence.
He began his elementary education at the age of seven and studied grammar
rhetoric as well as Latin.
Not much is known about Macchia of how these young life,
aside from the fact that he was well versed in the ancient classics among these
he highly prized as copy of levees history of the Roman republic.
Machiavelli's first recorded involvement in the volatile Florentine political
scene occurred in 1498 when he helps the political faction that depose gear
alarm,
oh Savonarola,
who was the then dominance,
religious and political figure in Florence.
In the same year,
Macchia valley was appointed to the second chancery of the Republic as
Chancellor and secretary to the 10 of liberty and peace,
a sensitive government agency dealing chiefly with warfare and foreign affairs.
Machiavelli participating in both domestic politics and in diplomatic missions
to foreign governments.
These posts allowed him many opportunities over the next 14 years,
which allowed him to closely examine the inner workings of government,
the awesome as many prominent individuals among them.
Cesari Borgia who furnished the young diplomats with the major profile of
leadership for the Prince Lakia value.
Quickly gains political prominence and influence by 15 oh [inaudible].
He was a well respected assistant to be Republican.
Head of state,
Piero Soderini in 1512 Spanish forces invaded Italy and the Florentine political
climates changed abruptly.
The Medici family where the rulers of Florence for centuries,
but in 1494 and they were exiled,
allowing for an autocratic regime to seize,
not here valley.
It was purged from office jails and then tortured for is well known Republican
sentiments.
It was also finally banished to his country of residence in pack Kasina.
You've already spent this time offering these small body of political writings
that sealed his place in history completed between 1513 and 1517 discourses upon
the first decade of t Livia and the prints were not published until after
Machiavelli's death in 1531 and 1532 respectively.
Around 1518 he turned from pros to drama in La.
Mandra Gola likely offers other writings.
It is firmly predicated on an astute and unsentimental awareness that human
nature is flawed and given to self centeredness.
The play was popular with audiences throughout much of Italy for several years.
Isn't that Steph say,
military treatise published in 1521 and didn't title the Libero.
Della Rta dela Guerra.
The Art of war was the only historical or political work published during the
author's lifetime.
Meanwhile,
Macchia valley had made several attempts to gain favor with the Medici,
including dedicating the Prince de Lorenzo in 1520 he was appointed official
historian of Florence and was subsequently and trusted with minor governmental
duties.
His prodigious history of Florence carefully dilutes his Republican platform
with the DC and bias expected of him.
In 1525 pope Clement the seventh recognize his achievements with a monetary
stipends two years later,
the Medici where again,
ousted and Macchia valley's hopes for advancement under the revived republic.
We're frustrated this was because the new governments were suspicious of his
ties to the Medici Dessau,
Austin's by his country's internal strife,
Macchia value fell gravely ill and died a disillusions man.
His dream of an operational republic.
Unrealized critics have found it ironic that the fist and the Republican
Machiavelli should have written a handbook advising an autocratic leader how
best to acquire and maintain power and security.
Machiavelli was acutely aware,
however,
foreign threats to Italian autonomy and is thus deemed necessary for a strong
prince.
Two fought French and Spanish hedger money.
Hence the Prince was addressed to the ruling MEDICI.
He believes there's a shrewd head of state exemplified by Boria was essential to
sublimated self interest to Commonwealth,
that since handbooks of conduct music monarchal needs had become immensely
popular by the 14 hundreds the external form of the prince was neither startling
nor particularly remarkable to Machiavelli's contemporaries.
Yet from its initial appearance,
the prince proved no mere manual of protocol,
nor for even that matter of even conventional strategy in its chapters,
Machiavelli delineated a typology of sovereignties and the deployment of
available forces,
military,
political or psychological,
to acquire and retain them.
The prince is the first political treaters to divorce statecraft from ethics as
Machiavelli wrote,
how one lives is so far removed from how one ought to live,
that he who abandons what one does for what one ought to do,
learns rather his own ruin than is preservation adding to his unflinching
realism.
The common renaissance belief in humanity has capacity for determining its same
destiny.
Machiavelli evaluate,
posited to fundamentals and necessary for effective political leadership,
Vertigo and for tuna virtually refers to the princess own abilities,
ideally a combination of force and cunning four to now to the unpredictable
influence of fortune and a significant departure from previous political
thought.
The designs of providence play no part in Machiavelli's skim on issues of
leadership.
Heather t masked by other political theorists in vague,
diplomatic terms.
Machiavelli presented his thesis in direct Kansas and often passionate speech.
He employed easily grasped metaphors and structured the whole thing and an
aphoristic vein,
which lends it a compelling authority.
Reactions to the prince miss initially,
but only briefly favorable.
We've Catherine de Medici said to have enthusiastic included this among other of
Machiavelli's writings in the educational curriculum of our children,
but within a short time,
the book fell in z widespread disfavor becoming viewed as a handbook for
atheistic tyranny.
The Prince Sends Akea Valleys,
other writings as well what placed in the people index if prohibited books.
And 1559 the prince was also held responsible for fringe political corruption
and for widespread contribution to any number of political and moral vices.
Genzler lays interpretation of the prince as advocating stage craft by
ruthlessness and amoral.
Duplicity was disseminated throughout Britain through the works of such popular
rens,
highly influential dramatists as William Shakespeare and Christopher Marlowe in
the prologue to Marlowe's the Jew of Malta from 50 99 Machiavelli addresses the
audience so length at one point encapsulating the Elizabethan perception of
Machiavelli by saying I count religion.
There's a childish toy and holds.
There is no sin but ignorance here and in the works of malaise contemporaries,
Machiavelli was depicted as an agents of all the Protestant England despised in
Catholic high renaissance Italy.
Hostile English interpreters so effectively typified Macchia valley as an
amalgam of various evils.
The term Machiavellian is still used today,
rally until the 19th century.
Did mention of the prince solicit anything other than unfounded as largely
unexamined repugnance as Freddy Cheer.
Pally has absolutely summarized centuries,
have to elapse before the distinction between moral moments and political
moments between technical approach and moralistic generalities.
Even between the subject matter of the book and the authors person,
we're finally achieved modern critics noting these crucial distinctions,
having engaged in a prolonged and animated discussion concerning Macchia values.
True intent in the prince and anomalous 17th century commentator philosopher
Pierre Bayle found it strange that there are so many people who believe that
Machiavel teaches prince's dangerous politics.
For on the contrary,
it princess of taught Mackey ravel what he has risen since bales time.
Further analysis is prompted to the most prolonged animated discussion relating
to the work.
The true intents of its creator was the treatise as bail suggested,
a faithful representation of principally contact,
which might justify or the incriminated subjects,
but not it's chronic Heller or had Macchia valley in his manner of presentation,
devise the volume as a vehicle for his own commentary.
Still more calculatedly at the author superseded description in ably providing a
legacy for dead spots.
A single conclusion concerning the author's motive has not been drawn.
The patterns of conjecture of certainly appeared within Macchia valleys.
Critical heritage Lord Macaulay and emphasizing the writers Republican Zealand,
those privation see suffered in its behalf,
has contended that it is inconceivable that the motto of freedom should have
designed diddly acted as the apostle of tyranny.
The peculiar immorality which is rendered the prince and popular belonged rather
to the age than to the man.
Others have echoed this suggestion examining the work and its historical
context.
John Addington Simons has deemed it simply a handbook of prince crafts.
As that art was commonly received,
Nestle,
where the principles of public morality had been translated into terms of
material aggrandizement,
glory gain,
and greatness.
Many of Machiavelli intended the treatise as a veiled satiric attack on the
methods of Italian tyranny or by a truce methods.
It's confess according to Harold j Lasky,
the prince is a textbook for the house of Muddy.
See sit hounds in the tons that I mean history would make them appreciate it and
set out that it's author might hope for their realization of his insights into
the business of government while ultimately unable to agree on the underlying
purpose of the prince.
Nearly all critics have nonetheless been persuaded of it's masterful
composition,
even when unwilling to endorse its principles.
Mccauley has a firms that's the judicious ends.
Ken's in minds of Macchia valley shows itself in his luminous manly and it's
polished language and Francesco to sanctus has determined to this where he was
quite unconscious a form.
He was a master a form without looking for Italian prose.
You found it.
The sheer volume and intensity studies of the prince of far exceeded those
directed a Mackie of how these discourses.
However,
the last work has been acknowledged as an essential companion piece.
Do the format,
all of the authors,
subsequent studies treating history,
political science and military theory stem from this dissertation that contains
the most original thought of Macchia valley,
less flamboyant than the prints and narrow or in its margin for interpretation.
The discourses contains Macchia Valleys,
undisguised admiration for ancient governmental forms and is most elegant,
thoroughly explicated republicanism.
Commentators have noted the presence of gravity and Skillful Rick that at times
punctuate prince but are in full evidence only in that works.
Final chapter,
a memorable exhortation to the Medicis to resist foreign tyranny.
The discourse is also presents that methodical extrapolation of political theory
from historical documentation,
which is intimate and in the Prince Max.
Alina has observed this if the prince is great because it gives us the grammar
of power for a government for discourse is a great because they give us the
philosophy of organic unity.
Knots in the governments put in a state and the conditions under which a loan a
culture can survive.
It has been deemed not at all in Congress that an intellect in Merced in
historical circumstance and political impetus should say naturally embrace
comedy as well.
For Machiavelli regarded comedy exactly as he conceived history and interplay of
forces leading unavoidably to a given results.
Machiavelli's manager Gola is only work in the comedic genre,
clearly reflected this parallel.
It's not practice has remarked this under the frivolous surface of Mandra Gola
are hidden.
The profoundest complexities of the inner life and to the action is propelled by
spiritual forces as inevitable as fate.
It is enough to know the characters to guests the ends,
the drama scenario concerns kind of Maca is desired to bed.
Lucretia,
the beautiful young wife of a doddering fool masquerading as a doctor at Maca
advises the husband Nikia to administer a potion of mandrake to the crees yet to
render her fertile.
He also warns that the drug could have fatal implications for the first man to
have intercourse.
With that,
he slightly suggest student Nikia.
There's a dup films for this purpose persuaded by her confessor ray navel cleric
to comply with her husband's wishes.
The virtuous new creature or the last allows Calico into her badge where he has
no difficulty convincing her to accept him as her lover on a more permanent
basis.
Sales of this sort,
we're already commonplace throughout Europe and the Middle Ages.
The critics have remarked that Machiavelli lent freshness to even this hackney
material,
Sydney Angler,
who has commended as clear,
crisp a rep,
our team,
and his ability to nudge on ribs at improprieties and double meanings,
just blind to characterization that is rudimentary,
haphazard,
and inconsistent with even protagonists going through their motions like
automata.
Mccauley,
on the other hand,
is applauded the players correct and vigorous delineation of human nature.
It decided influence on the philosophies of Thomas Hobbes and Sir Francis Bacon
and eggs on the thoughts of such modern political theorists says,
Vilfredo Pareto.
Machiavelli has been [inaudible] the founder of empirical political science,
primarily on the strength of the discourses and the prints taken in historical
perspective.
It is understandable that the prince should have dwarfed Machiavelli's other
works for with this slim treatise,
the author confronted the ramifications of power when it's procurement and
exercise,
when notably preemptory commentators have come to weigh the integrity of
Machiavelli's controversial fought against the pressing political conditions
which formed us.
So I'm like Roberto Ridalfi have endeavored through their studies to dislodge
the longstanding perception of Machiavelli valley as a ruthless character
stating in judging Macchia valley one to take accounts of his anguish,
despair of virtue,
and just tragic sense of evil on the basis of sentences taken out of context and
is of outward appearances.
He was judged a cold and cynical man,
a snare,
a to religion and virtue,
but in fact there is hardly a page of his writing and certainly no action of
life that does not show him to be passionate,
generous audits and basically religious Peter Bonds and other has stated in
European writers Makaveli.
It created a new religion out of politics with all its faithful implications for
modern intellectual history.
In 59 to Machiavelli married Marietta Corps Sini.
The couple had six children together,
four sons and two daughters.
Niccolo Machiavelli's the prince is one of the most celebrated and notorious
books in the history of Western political thought,
most celebrated and notorious books in the history of Western political thought.
It continues to influence discussions of war and peace,
the nature of politics and the relation of private ethics to public duties.
Ostensibly a 16th century manual of instruction on certain aspects of Princeton.
He rule in behavior.
The prints anticipates and complicates modern political and philosophical
questions.
What is the right order of society?
Can Western politics still be the model for progress toward peace and prosperity
or does our freedom to create our individual purposes and pursuits undermine our
public responsibilities?
Are the characters of our politics markedly different?
For better or for worse than the politics of the era's?
Machiavelli argues that there is no ideal transcending and daughter to which one
can conform and that the right order is merely the one that has the capacity to
persist over time.
The prince,
his emphasis on the importance of an effective truth over any abstract ideal
Marxist as one of the first works of modern political philosophy.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right and as always,
thank you.
Gotcha.